here the council we offer around 100
page traineeship per year and 20 more
that are actually part of their studies
we look for highly motivated people
basically one of the main tool of
selection is actually the motivation
letter and the more they put inside of
their person and of their real
motivation to come here the better it is
for for any chances to be to be selected
and we look for very very different
backgrounds because one might have the
impression that we only look for more
political background or Foreign Affairs
but actually we need transport experts
we need informaticians we need
archivists translators of course this
program also to see the institutions
here so they have meetings at the
Commission and the Economic and Social
Committee committee of regions and then
we also organise a council simulation
exercise that is a very very highly
valued by by the trainees at the end of
the experience where they actually are
put in to the places of ambassadors and
and ministers and they have to try and
find a solution to a to a real problem
and not particularly defending their own
real opinion but the one given by the
other so this program is quite extensive
and is a scope is to give a deeper
knowledge of the European Union as such
or European institutions in this case as
such and also to create a bonding
feeling amongst them so they can go away
at the end of their training shape
having you know a network we have a very
high rate of job finding after after the
end of our training
you